IT'S TIME FOR THE SEGMENT WE
LIKE TO CALL "KEEP IT 100."
THERE WE GO.
FOR ALL YOU PEOPLE WHO DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT EXPRESSION MEANS,
IT MEANS "KEEP IT 100% REAL."
ALL RIGHT? IF YOU GUYS KEEP IT
100% REAL
YOU GET A STICKER. IF YOU
DON'T WE'RE GOING TO THROW
SOME WEAK TEA AT YOU, ALL RIGHT?
JUDD, LET'S START WITH YOU.
IN HONOR YF YOUR MOVIE
"TRAINWRECK," CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU HAD GREAT WEEKEND.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
VERY FUNNY, AMY SCHUMER, WHO I
IMAGINE IS THE "TRAINWRECK" IN
QUESTION.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
Larry: HERE IS YOUR QUESTION.
WHO IS BIGGER TRAINWRECK, AMY
SCHUMER OR LENA DUNHAM?
>> OOH.
THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
(LAUGHTER)
I NEVER EVEN PONDERED TO THINK
THAT.
>> Larry: THAT'S MY JOB.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
PRODUCTION HAS WRAPPED.
THE MOVIE'S OUT.
SCHUMER!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: IS HE KEEPING IT 100?
GOOD JOB.
50, WHO KEEPING ON THE
TRAINWRECK THING, WHO'S A BIGGER
TRAINWRECK DIDDY OR JA RULE?
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
YOU CAN PUT YOURSELF IN THERE
TOO.
>> I LIKE ME OUT OF THAT ONE.
NO, BUT JA RULE--
Larry: THAT WAS PRETTY FAST.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HUNDRED?
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT WERE YOU GOING TO SAY?
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY MINE
WAS EASIER THAN HIS.
(LAUGHTER)
BECAUSE I --
>> Larry: THEY GET HARDER AS WE
GO ALONG.
>> I DIDN'T HAVE LIKE THE THREAT
OF VIOLENCE OR ANYTHING.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: THE DEGREE OF
DIFFICULTY INCREASES.
LOOK AT RACHEL GETTING ALL
SCARED.
>> I KNOW BECAUSE I GOT TEA
LAST TIME, I DON'T WANT IT.
>> Larry: YOU WERE IN
"TRAINWRECK."
>> YOU SHOULD HAVE ASKED ME IF
SHE WAS A TRAINWRECK.
>> Larry: OKAY.
YOU WORKED WITH JUDD AND YOU
WORKED WITH ME HERE.
SO WHO'S A BIGGER TRAINWRECK,
JUDD OR ME?
[ AUDIENCE OOHs ]
KEEP IN MIND "TRAINWRECK" HAS
WRAPPED.
>> YEAH.
HONESTLY, I -- LIKE I GUESS I
SPEND MORE TIME WITH JUDD AT
THIS POINT.
SO I'D HAVE TO SAY YOU.
YOU COULD HAVE SKELETONS NO ONE
KNOWS ABOUT.
>> Larry: I'M THE BIGGER
TRAINWRECK?
[ AUDIENCE OOHs ]
>> OH, WHATEVER!
I KNEW THEY WERE GOING TO ATTACK
ME.
I KNEW IT.
>> Larry: WHAT SHOULD I GIVE
HER?
I DON'T KNOW.
RACHEL, I'LL GIVE YOU A HUNDRED
BUT YOU NEVER CALL ME A
TRAINWRECK.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)